what's popping primates it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
y'all and I hope yall like animals that
go in the night because it is time to
book a trip to Skull Island with Tom
Heston and Brie Larsson Donkey Kong
Country has never been so brutal son
especially when you add a bit of that
Vietnam War flavor so let's stop
monkeying about and just swing on into
this thing shall we but hey before we do
maybe take a second and use your
favorite finger to hit that like and or
subscribe button or maybe you could be a
little extra naughty and use your least
favorite finger to spice things up like
every single like goes a long way to
supporting the heavy spoilers Channel
but if you really want to add some spice
to your life maybe even consider
becoming a member today at just 99 cents
a month getting early access to
top-notch movie breakdowns before
anybody else has never been so damn
affordable like I bet you won't even
notice that that dang dollar is gone but
if you are not a baller like that no
worries we're just glad you're here
anyways Kong Skull Island was directed
by Jordan VA Roberts and released on
March 10th 2017 and was the first King
Kong movie since Peter Jackson's beloved
2005 King Kong which meant that Kong
Skull Island had some pretty dang big
gorilla Footprints to fill in but that
was a challenge that Jordan VA Roberts
and his team were more than willing to
tackle with a 1970s flare while VA
Roberts very much appreciated the
original 1933 King Kong film he wanted
to introduce a completely new kind of
Kong in his own unique way that nobody
had really seen before and Jordan VA
Roberts thought the best way to do this
was by giving Kong Skull Island a 1973
setting heavily wrapped within themes of
the Vietnam War a war that plays a
significant role within the plot of this
film as Jordan Vault Roberts was heavily
inspired by Francis capa's 1979 Vietnam
War film Apocalypse Now like Kong Skull
Island is just straight up Apocalypse
Now with a tall ass Donkey Kong if you
think about it with Skull Island itself
being a narrative parallel to the
country of Vietnam and it's a big reason
why the director chose to actually film
in Vietnam with the majority of the cast
being absolutely amazed as to how
beautiful the country of Vietnam
actually was the IMAX poster for Kong
Skull Island was actually a direct
tribute to Apocalypse Now as well but
before vot Roberts got involved with the
film The Original script was actually
set almost 60 years prior in the year
1917 but anyways let us talk about the
absolutely genius way this movie starts
off by having a young Hank Maro falling
downwards from the sky because this
opening perfectly encapsulates a major
theme of this movie The metaphorical
dangers of flying too damn close to the
Sun as originally detailed in the
ancient Greek tragedy of Icarus Colonel
Packard actually references the tale of
Icarus early on in the movie as his
Fleet of helicopters first approach
Skull Island for those of you who do not
know this ancient Greek tale is about a
boy named Icarus who along with his
father tried to fly away from an island
that they're trapped on by using Wings
made out of wax but Icarus would ignore
his father's warnings and fly too high
and close to the Sun causing Icarus to
plummet to the ground after his wax
wings inevitably melted by starting Kong
Skull Island with this imagery of a
young Hank Maro falling from a sunny Sky
vot Roberts establishes this movie
strong Icarus Sun theme from the jump as
it very much proves to be Central to the
overall progression of of the film as
Colonel Packard would prove to be the
foolish Icarus of the story with King
Kong himself becoming the very son that
Packard desperately tries to reach no
matter how many men he may lose along
the way because much like Icarus Packard
did not like being told not to do
something especially after the sting
that came with the news that America was
withdrawing from the Vietnam War
Packard's bald black ass could not stand
that the United States was just running
from the people that Packard was led to
believe were the evil eny enemy and that
anger and shame Packard felt about
losing the Vietnam War Amplified
exponentially as soon as Kong showed up
to give Packard a whole new war to fight
not only is this why Kong is framed
within the burning Sun when he makes his
first appearance in the movie but it's
also why Kong Skull Island begins and
ends with Zoomin to golden yellow
eyeballs that were very much designed to
look like burning Suns I mean the
freaking logo for Packard Sky Devil's
helicopter Squadron also reflects
Packard's obsession with ing the Sun as
we can see that it's just a giant
Griffin raising its winged arms to try
and reach a sun but actually fun fact
about this Sky Devil's logo director
Jordan VA Roberts revealed on Twitter a
few years ago that this design was
heavily inspired by the high and
Triforce design from The Legend of Zelda
series which I thought was super dope as
the Triforce in Zelda is also heavily
associated with the sun like I could
honestly do a whole breakdown series on
the Legends of Zelda and its links to
the sun because I freaking love that
franch so damn much and appreciate
Jordan's nerd levels greatly like we
need more nerds directing films man but
anyways not only is this Sun theme
Central to this movie but once you
notice it you'll also begin to
understand why Kong marketing materials
throughout all of his monsterverse
movies are typically themed with yellow
and orange because Kong species was
exiled from the hollow Earth to Skull
Island aass time ago Kong species became
more associated with the yellow orange
Sun that powered the world of the humans
more so than the mysterious blue Hollow
Earth radioactive power source that
powers Titans like Godzilla so if you
look at the logo for the new Godzilla X
Kong movie coming out for example you'll
see that Godzilla is in blue and Kong is
in orangey yellow for this reason
actually go into this a little during my
breakdowns of the last few episodes of
legendary's Monarch Legacy of Monsters
TV series so definitely check those out
if you love The monsterverse and haven't
seen those already but anyways back to
the opening the young Maro let Falls is
actually played by actor Will Brittain
with John C Riley's voice dubbed over
will Brittain would appear in the movie
again as a completely different
character in the form of Hank Marlo's
son but if you look at Marlo's jacket
you can see the words good for your
health written on the back this is
actually a pretty sweet double layered
Easter egg because it's a reference to
Canada's jacket from the 1988 anime
classic Akira that says the words good
for your health bad for your education
on the back while also being a nod to
John see Riley's character Dr Steve
Brule from the TV show check it out with
Dr Steve Brule where his slogan is for
your health and on the front side of
Marlo's jacket you can see a patch with
the words lizard company on it much like
the director took inspiration with the
sky Devil's logo vot Roberts also
designed Marlo's lizard company patch
after being inspired by Travis ble King
Kong company patch from the movie Taxi
Driver as this Travis character fought
in the Vietnam war with this fake
company but anyway anyways young Maro
lands on Skull Island during a World War
II dog fight gone wrong with his soon
Tobe best friend gunpei aari who at the
time was fighting for the Japanese Army
according to the director gunpei aari's
name is a tribute to Shinji aari from
the anime Neon Genesis Evangelion as
well as video game Legend gunpei yokoi
who was instrumental for a number of
Nintendo successes like you know
creating The Game and Watch system
designing the original Game Boy and
producing a number of classic Nintendo
titles with the original Donkey Kong
being his first Banger so I feel like it
was very fitting for this man to get a
shout out in a Kong movie then after we
get a zoom in on Marlo's eye that pupil
turns into a son as the Kong Skull
Island title comes up the opening credit
sequence opens up with a July 20th 1945
quote from President Truman that he said
during the raising of the American flag
at Berlin following Germany's surrender
of World War II then we get images of
Americans celebrating victory over Japan
on August 15th 19 1945 AKA VJ Day before
getting this Frame that says us unveils
Earth satellite as audio from president
isenhower October 1957 remarks about the
US development of Earth satellites play
but if you look at this Frame notice how
the top of it is blue while the bottom
is orange much like how the logo for the
LSAT satellite monitoring organization
is modeled after these two blue and
orange Suns like I said before this is
the monster verse way of teasing the two
separate Realms of the blue irradiated
Hollow Earth and the orange solar
irradiated human Earth since landat
stands for land satellite having the
hollow Earth blue sun over the word land
and then having the orange Sun under the
word sat in Satellite was a perfect way
to allude to both these Subterranean and
outer space cosmic energy sources
because the hollow Earth is in the land
and satellites are in space like the sun
then a little later as John Ortiz's name
appears on the screen a message from
president Harry Truman authorizing
Monarch's project Muto flashes in the
background a message which gave General
Pucket the go-ahead to attempt The
Castle Bravo nuclear bombing of Godzilla
at bikini Adel this letter made a brief
appearance at the start of 2014's
Godzilla movie as it marked the very
first time that the United States
government decided to take massive
unidentified terrestrial organisms or
mutos like Godzilla and Kong seriously
then a little after this we see a
newspaper article that says government
denies missing third ship with that
article being a reference to the USS
lotton ship that bill Randa was the only
Survivor of something that Randa himself
mentions while trying to acquire
government assistance for his field trip
to hell we of course learn in Monarch
Legacy of monsters that the USS Latin
somehow found its way to the jungles of
the Philippines after being attacked by
a mysterious Kaiju likely the ion Dragon
found on the scene then after we see
some footage of the Russian launch of
the Sputnik one the first satellite in
space we soon see these images of
various mutos skeletons from the CIA
with one of them possibly being the
skull of one of Kong's species then
after this we get a quick flash of the
Monarch logo with the X-ray of some type
of snake or eel Kaiju followed by this
drawing of a turtle Muto that could
either be a reference to the magma
Turtles featured in the prequel comic
skull Islands the birth of Kong or could
also be a slight nod to the competing
monster property gamra who is basically
just a big ass Turtle Godzilla knockoff
but whose character is still very much
loved by the people of Japan today like
the Japanese really love their Kaiju man
then a little after this we get flashes
of a monkey carrying a baby up a tree
branch quickly followed by an image of
an octopus camouflaging into their
surroundings possible foreshadowing to
when Kong himself is attacked by an
octopus later on in the movie a quote
from Arthur C Clark about the future of
mankind being dominated by machines
instead of man or monkeys can be heard
following this very much foreshadowing
Apex cybernetics secret plans of
becoming the top apex predator on Earth
with their Mecca Godzilla program then
John F Kennedy September 1962 speech
about America's efforts to go to the
Moon play before we get a bunch of
flashes of historical footage including
the Apollo 11 space launch to the Moon a
1960 Civil Rights march the first walk
on the moon and War reels from the the
Vietnam War we then get a quote from
Robert Kennedy that mentions an old
Greek saying about taming the savageness
of man and making gentle with the life
of this world which is the perfect way
to end this opening credit sequence as
it perfectly encapsulates the overall
struggle of this movie taming the
savageness of war-hungry men like
Packard to try to make gentle with the
life of Skull Island then the opening
itself finally Ends by transitioning to
the scene of a 1973 Vietnam war protest
at Washington DC where Bill Randa and
Houston Brooks arrive at the capital to
beg for funding for their Skull Island
Excursion and judging by Randa and
Brooks watching Nixon announced the end
of the Vietnam War on TV when they
arrive for their begging session the
date of their arrival looks to be
January 23rd 1973 to be exact then after
Senator Willis gets Randa his piggyback
with lanat and calls up Packard for the
military escort we head to Saigon and
get a shot of a life Magazine's year in
picture review for the year 197 3 with a
cover featuring Richard Nixon a space
satellite the Vietnam War and tennis
player Billy Jean King when Randa and
Brooks enter the bar the 1967 song White
Rabbit by Jefferson Airplane can be
heard playing in the background then we
finally meet Tom heston's James Conrad
with Heston himself actually filming
this movie back to back with Thor
Ragnarok because your boy stay booked
and busy but speaking of Marvel actors
after this we meet Brie larsson's Mason
Weaver as she gets a phone call giving
her the goad head to attend lad's survey
of Skull Island the dude on the phone
mentions that Weaver is so damn good at
being a photographer that she'll soon
have her photographs featured on the
cover of Time Magazine which is quite
the professional achievement then as the
sky Devils get ready for launch we get a
look at the back of one of their helmets
which contain a wing skull of a demon
perfectly encapsulating the sky devil
theme and in direct reference to their
company logo Packard calls the sky
Devils deployment the Griffin and ant
show with the very people that they're
leaving behind on the boat disappearing
and becoming like ants as they ascend
Into the Storm and like I mentioned
before as the sky Devils navigate skull
Island's Perpetual storm Colonel Packard
recites the tale of Icarus and brags
about how the US government isn't an
irresponsible father like he felt Icarus
dad was which is quite ironic
considering that Packard's irresponsible
leadership is exactly what leads to him
losing most of the sky Devils including
himself like Packard's prideful nature
is exactly what led actor Samuel L
Jackson to rightfully compare his
character to The Reckless Captain Ahab
of Moby Dick before they all enter the
storm Samuel L Jackson tells everyone to
hold on to their butts which is a clear
reference to the same line that he said
in 1993's Jurassic Park but after the
group clears the storm these Devils of
the sky drop their seismic bombs onto
the unsuspecting populace of Skull
Island allowing Houston Brooks and
Sunland to discover that the Earth under
the island is completely Hollow the very
first clue that would lead on to proving
Brooks and randa's Hollow Earth theories
but unfortunately for them these deadly
explosions trigger the arrival of skull
Island's greatest Defender Of Life Kong
who enters the movie by throwing a whole
ass tree at one of these sky devil
helicopters leaving all of these men to
die without knowing that a giant gorilla
LED them to an early grave the very
beginning of the very first episode of
Monarch Legacy of monsters throws it
back to this chaotic moment in Kong
Skull Island as the Griffin themed Sky
Devils face off against Kong fans of the
original 1933 King Kong movie can
definitely see how Kong Skull Island
paid homage to the iconic scene of Kong
fighting those airplanes at the top of
the Empire State Building but
unfortunately for Packard and his Sky
Devils they all flew too damn close to
the son of the Kong Legacy and as a
result this pissed-off not gorilla
clipped the Wings off of the Griffin and
sent all of those helicopters Hur in to
the ground and right when Kong cuts off
Paranoid by Black Sabbath we get this
Ultra Cool shot of this helicopter
spinning out of control a shot that
Jordan v Robert says was inspired by a
Moment from one of the Resident Evil
video games that he played if I had to
guess Which Resident Evil moment that
this director was referring to it's
probably the helicopter crash scene from
2012's Resident Evil 6 and I freaking
love this shot of Kong standing to face
the remaining sky devil helicopters with
the sun behind him because you can can
literally see all of these dumb asses
approach this destructive force of
nature just as foolishly as Icarus did
in the myth and it's a shot that shows
just how different this Kong's stature
is from Peter Jackson's Kong from 2005
as legendary's Kong stands completely
upright compared to Peter Jackson's who
walked using his hands like a
traditional silverback gorilla but since
Kong isn't a gorilla at all and is
instead a member of the titanous Kong
species Kong Skull Island went with the
upright approach and I really dig this
decision as I feel Kong standing on two
feet shows just how evolved this king of
Skull Island is in comparison to all the
other Kaiju found on that island because
if you think about it up until this
point in the monsterverse Kong has
really been the only one of these Kaiju
with these sentience to use objects like
trees chains and boat propellers as
weapons during battle a cognitive
advantage that has allowed him to become
skull Island's undefeated Defender but
what's so great about Kong's evolved
mind is that he doesn't use his super
Superior intellect to be cruel towards
others but is completely dedicated to
protecting the lives of his neighbors
from anything that might do them harm a
spirit of compassion that likely stems
from the traumatic loneliness that comes
from being the last of one's kind but
anyways after Nick Fury makes sure that
Casey the analyst is okay after getting
messed up by a Megazord monkey Packard
regroups with his men and then points a
gun straight at William randa's face who
then proceeds to tell Packard that he
only arranged this trip to Skull Island
in order to prove to everyone that
monsters like the ion dragon and
Godzilla do exist so that he didn't
spend the last 30 years of his life
trying to avenge the loss of his wife K
Randa for nothing but we wouldn't learn
that last part until Monarch Legacy of
monsters but hey fun fact about Bill
Randa the hat and vest that he wears
throughout the movie appears to be a
tribute to the character Carl denim from
the original 1933 King Kong film but
anyways as Conrad's group of pacifists
walk through the marshlands of Skull
Island they luckily come across a
peaceful giant Yak looking scur Buffalo
one of the few herb of wars that we meet
on Skull Island while Packer's group of
War Dogs has significantly less luck as
they run into a group of mother longleg
spiders spiders that take out a few of
their own in the most brutal ways
possible then Conrad's group unknowingly
approaches an ewee settlement causing
Weaver to be surprised when one of the
nearby walls turns into a camouflaged
woman and Weaver should be scared as
that woman literally has her face like
that is just straight up brie Larsson in
makeup pointing a spear at Brie Larsson
which is quite hilarious this
confrontation then of course leads to
John C Riley's older Hank Marlo to
approach and diffuse the tension telling
the group that they were all as
beautiful as a hot dog and a beer at
Ringley field on opening day which is
foreshadowing to the end of the movie
when we see Marlo enjoying a hot dog and
beer while watching the Chicago Cubs on
TV after this we catch up with Billy's
soon to be slain dad major Jack chap as
played by actor Toby keble who just 3
years prior put out an amazing
performance as the ape kobba in 2014's
Dawn of the Planet of the Apes due to
his past experience with motion
capturing Toby keble does double duty in
Kongo Island by becoming the reference
for Kong's facial animations while actor
Terry notary was used for Kong's actual
movements but anyways as Chapman stands
by this large body of water he fails to
notice the giant tentacle of a Meer
squid just barely breach the surface
like were it not for the sudden
appearance of Kong looking to have a
quick drink and a squid meal after
licking his wounds Chapman himself would
have become a different kind of squid
meal but luckily for him he would become
a skull crawler meal instead because
that Chapman got chomped
man after this the group follow Maro
through the ewi camp into the
Shipwrecked remains of a ship called The
Wanderer that appears to have wandered
off a little farther than intended
thanks to the mysterious storm that has
kept Skull Island a mystery to the rest
of the world this ship is a reference to
The Wanderer ship from the 1932 written
novelization of the 1933 King Kong movie
for mysterious reasons the 1933 Kong
movie calls Carl denim ship the Venture
whereas the novelization that came up
the previous year refers to the ship as
The Wanderer so Jordan VA Roberts
decided to pay tribute to the ship from
the book instead as that one came first
but anyways we then learned that the ewe
converted this Shipwrecked Wanderer into
a holy site that details the history of
the Kong species who the ewe regard as
their saviors after thousands of years
of these ewi being hunted down and eaten
by the skull crawlers the Kong species
emerged from the hollow Earth to drive
the skull crawlers back and defend the
ewe however by 1973 Kong's entire family
had been wiped out by the biggest skull
crawler of them all the skull devil
leaving Kong with the double duty of
Avenger and Defender as the very last of
his kind and during this explanation we
we get our first look at the skull
crawler species a species that director
Jordan v Roberts said he designed
specifically after the first Angel
monster from the anime Neon Genesis
Evangelion the character no face from
the anime Spirited Away and the Pokemon
Cubone from the hit video game series
pal
world and speaking of video games a
little later Marlo introduces Conrad's
group to his gray fox makeshift boat
that he and gunpei worked on in the past
with gray fox being a reference to the
character gray fox from the Metal Gear
Solid video game franchise as Jordan
Vault Roberts would soon be tapped to
direct the upcoming Metal Gear film
starring Oscar Isaac as Solid Snake but
don't get too excited because you know
it's AV Arad uh producing this one so
you
know [__] and if you couldn't already
tell by now Jordan VA Roberts is a
massive fan of video games which is why
we get first-person shooter camera
angles a number of times during this
movie and aboard the gry fox one of
Marlo's baseballs signed by Chicago Cub
outfielder Bill Nicholson can be seen
attached and while they're repairing the
boat one of the Lancet scientists
informs Maro that Humanity sent a man to
the Moon which is quite ironic
considering that that very same
scientist would have his limbs removed
in front of the sun after being lifted
into the Sky by a pack of leaf Wings
then a little later we meet up again
with Chapman for the last time who ends
up shooting at a harmless wooden SPO or
mantis bug but unfortunately for Chapman
those needless gunshots were all a
nearby skull crawler needed to make sure
that Billy never saw his dad again once
again proving that making peace with
nature like Conrad's group does is the
way to survive on Skull Island after
this when the Sun goes down Conrad's
group heads to Marlo's place for the
night and listen to Ziggy Stardust by
David Bowie as Marlo is shaving his
beard behind Marlo you can see the
shadow of an old school movie camera
according to visual effects artist Jeff
white this camera in the background is
the exact same camera used by Carl denim
in the 1933 King Kong film which I
thought was a wild Easter egg to throw
in the shadows I also thought it was a
nice touch to have Maro shave his beard
in front of a cracked mirror as that
seems deliberately symbolic of his own
inner cracked psyche and while this is
happening Brooks tells Lynn about how he
met Bill Randa after presenting his
hollow Earth theory to his fellow
colleagues only to be laughed at but fun
fact about these two characters while
this movie doesn't do a fantastic job at
developing son Lin's character we do
learn in the Skull Island birth of Kong
comic that Houston Brooks and Son Linn
actually get married after these events
and have a child named Aaron Brooks who
eventually grows up to become a security
officer for Monarch so definitely keep
an eye out for that character if Monarch
Legacy of monsters gets a second season
as Aaron Brooks has a close connection
with Skull Island and as Weaver and
Conrad have their own heart tohe heart
Conrad reveals that his father was part
of part of the British royal Air Force
and that Conrad thought his father was
as cool as John Wayne one of the kings
of the western film genre then a little
later after Conrad's group leaves the
ewi tribe on the gray fox they reunite
with Packard's group and stumble across
the grave site of Kong's parents a grave
site crawling with skull crawlers
leading the group to literally crawl
inside of a Kong skull themselves to
avoid detection but unfortunately Bill
Randa would be amongst those who become
skullcrawler food along with this sky
devil who sat himself at Top This
Triceratop skull rip random guy but
anyways moving on later on at night
Conrad and Weaver are surprised by the
sudden appearance of the king of Kongs
himself an event that would surely
increase the brown levels of my boxers
exponentially if that happened to me but
Weaver having a braver soul than mine
actually takes the opportunity to reach
out and touch Kong leading to one of my
favorite moments of the film as it shows
truly just how lonely this massive
Island Guardian has become come in his
very young age being the last of a
species exiled from their original
Hollow Earth home Dimension Kong has
largely grown up in near complete
isolation with no one to really call his
family as his entire species was wiped
out by the skull crawler population much
like Godzilla species were wiped out by
the jinin musim mudo Kaiju that Godzilla
got Vengeance on in Godzilla 2014 I
truly love Kong's reaction to Weaver's
empathetic touch as this is the first
time that we see Kong put the tough guy
act to the side for 2 seconds to soak in
and appreciate a living being on the
island trying to connect with him and of
course Weaver's bonding moment with Kong
is actually part of a long tradition of
leading woman in Kong movies as Kong
apparently has a weakness for uh
attractive white women a weakness that I
too share from time to time just joking
I love all kinds of women women are all
beautiful but as nice as this moment is
it's kind of wild looking back at it
knowing that nobody on the cast actually
knew how Big King Kong was actually
supposed to be so Brie Larson and Tom
hilston didn't really have much to go on
during this moment outside of there's a
big ass monkey in front of you so you
know act
surprised Kong actually stood at a
staggering 104 ft tall during the events
of Kong Skull Island in 1973 and while
this is big enough to make him Tower
above the Dennison of Skull Island like
the gorilla God that he is he was still
very much a growing boy at this point
which explains why by the time he faces
off against Godzilla 51 years later in
the year 2024 he would grow to a
whopping 335 ft for comparison the
original 1933 King Kong was 50 feet tall
while Peter Jackson's 2005 Kong was only
25 feet tall so needless to say if it
ever came down to it legendaries Kong
would eat those other two Kongs for
breakfast because that's one big ass boy
but anyways later after Kong kills
Samuel L Jackson in the middle of him
saying [__] much like Thanos
would do do in Infinity War we get the
dramatically comical death of Earl Cole
who explodes after trying to trick the
skull devil into eating him however
though it appears like Cole died in vain
it seems like his explosion was exactly
what Kong needed to find out where the
skull devil was so that he could
brutally end that skull Devil's life and
as the movie wraps up we of course get
to see Hank Marlo's long awaited reunion
with his wife and son before Marlo gets
to pop open a cold one and enjoy a Cubs
game on TV but seeing as Maro is
revealed to have a son here this kind of
makes me wonder if Tim from Monarch
Legacy of monsters could potentially be
one of Marlo's descendants like that
monsterverse TV series has done a
spectacular job of mashing up the
families of monsterverse characters that
we've seen before in previous films like
it did with both the Randa and Brody
families so it wouldn't be too much of a
shock to me if the mysterious Tim with
no confirmed last name was revealed to
be the descendant of Hank Maro and his
son one who joined Monarch after hearing
the Tales of his grandfather who
survived on a mysterious island of
monsters but that's just a wild Theory
to be honest and finally we have the
post-credit scene very much meant to
tease the next movie Down legendaries
monsterverse pipeline 2019s Godzilla
king of the monsters Monarch agents
Brooks and Lynn hand Weaver and Conrad
classified Monarch files the first of
which include images that were included
during the opening of the 2014 Godzilla
film like the American military's
attempts to kill Godzilla with a nuke at
bikini all in 1954 as well as this map
of Japan but after this they are of
course shown photographs teasing at the
past influences of monsters that would
soon make themselves known to humanity
only a few short decades later monsters
like Godzilla Rodan Mathra and of course
the three-headed Hydra King gadora the
main big bad of Godzilla 2 but anyways
that is it for this breakdown of Kong
Skull Island thank you guys so much for
watching you guys are amazing you guys
can follow me at mastertainment on
Twitter YouTube Instagram or wherever I
am on the internet but most importantly
do not forget to follow heavy spoilers
here on YouTube give us a like hit
subscribe and even consider becoming a
member for only 99 cents a month so that
you can get early content before
everybody else but again thank you guys
so much for watching this video you guys
are amazing and I love you guys so much
and I'll see you guys next
time bye